une production du studio SF
iltre le podcast où on parle ce qu'on
veut que nos invités dans
cette semaine cette semaine onctualité
quand même on reçoit on parle d'un sujet
d'actualités
on parle d'alcool aujourd'hui avec Hugo
Munier qui a animé en fait qui en fait
non seulement animé
les répercussions de la colle sur la
santé puis aussi notre relation en tant
québécois avec l'alcool le rôle des sécu
le rôle des et du calcule ça s'appelle
péter la balle c'est vraiment bon je le
recommande puis ça tombe bien aussi
parce que il y a des nouvelles
recommandations qui ont été
sortis au grand jour
récemment sur quel devrait être la bonne
consommation d'alcool
pile la réponse selon ces
recommandations là c'est le moins
possible c'est possible 0 sinon le moins
possible le moins le mieux finalement
puis donc c'est super intéressant de
parler de ça puis de comprendre un petit
peu plus c'est quoi les effets de
l'alcool sur la santé parce qu'on le
sait on se doute que c'est pas super
mais on le sait pas à quel point on sait
pas exactement les impacts c'est pas
avoir sur le cerveau sur les risques de
cancer sur le microbiote tu sors
d'affaires en fait puis et puis c'est ça
c'était
on veut pas vous dire quoi faire puis je
pense pas que Hugo non plus même lui au
début du paquet vous allez voir même lui
va prendre sa propre décision avec les
informations qui sont là par contre moi
ce que je peux peut-être vous encourager
à faire c'est d'essayer de couper
l'alcool de votre vie pendant une
période X ou Y puis voir comment vous le
vivez en fait parce que moi je l'ai fait
plusieurs fois puis en ce moment je suis
dans même dans ce processus là puis si
jamais pour des raisons de dépendance
j'ai pas heureusement j'ai pas ce
problème là mais de le couper puis de
voir qu'est-ce que ça t'apporte ta vie
devient comment ça puis après ça
reprendre une décision éclairée avec
toutes les informations puis je pense
que ces informations qu'on essaie de
partager aujourd'hui puis évidemment il
y a plusieurs plusieurs
sources d'information plus spécifiques
que la conversation vous allez entendre
mais là aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
intéressant de ce questionner sur notre
relation avec ça puis Hugo il a fait le
travail pour nous tous en fait c'est ça
encore une fois c'est une question de
prendre une décision à partir de dans
votre tête d'informations le fait
qu'après ça suit faire du skateboard si
tu veux fumer
n'importe quoi dans le fond c'est juste
de savoir c'est quoi les c'est quoi les
risques qui sont qui sont encourus enfin
que mais moi je continue de boire
toujours boire beaucoup mais je bois
quand même pas que
[Musique]
[Rires]
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
menscape je suis vraiment excité
aujourd'hui parce que je peux enfin vous
parler et vous montrer des nouveaux
produits ça fait longtemps qu'on vous
parle du lomework 4.0 du parfum de tous
les produits qu'on adore déjà chez
manscape mais là enfin on a encore plus
de choses à vous montrer encore plus de
produits qu'on peut utiliser pour
l'entretien de soi et de son de son
apparence de son hygiène et aujourd'hui
c'est le build hadger c'est une tondeuse
spécialement faite pour la barbe et
c'est sans contredit la meilleure
tondeuse à barbe de tous les temps et ça
ça vient avec le pro kit le pro kit
c'est tout ce que vous avez besoin pour
l'entretien de votre barbe de A à Z
alors il y a 6 étapes à suivre qui sont
détaillées dans la boîte on commence
avec
le shampoing pour la barbe ensuite le
revitalisant ensuite avant de se raser
on se peigne la barbe un truc qu'elle
soit bien lisse qu'on n'est pas de de
nœud dans la barbe et ensuite comme je
le disais on sort le bear qu'on peut
régler à la longueur qu'on veut de.5
jusqu'à 10 pour avoir vraiment le look
exact qu'on veut après ça sur les petits
poils rebelles on a une part de ciseaux
qui met avec ça qu'on peut terminer
le notre look de barbe à la perfection
une petite brosse pour la placer ensuite
une pommade pour la barbe bien sûr et on
termine avec une petite tuile à barbe
pour être sûr qu'elle soit parfaitement
hydratée donc ça veut pas ça peut pas
être plus complet que ça ça peut vous
pouvez pas avoir une barbe plus on
pointe que ce c'est certain vous allez
avoir la barbe ultime tout le monde va
en parler tout le monde va vous
complimenter sur votre barbe vous allez
marcher dans la rue les gens vont vous
arrêter ils vont vous dire mon Dieu
jamais vu une barbe aussi bien
entretenue
si je t'avoue je pense ça va changer
votre vie en fait
c'est
presque certain
filtre et profitez-en puis amusez-vous
avec votre barbe essayez de nouveau
styles ça y est
osé quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut salut merci de m'inviter
[Rires]
merci
on peut dire ça
on boit pas en fait d'alcool
aujourd'hui
mais moi je bois plus j'ai arrêté
longtemps l'année passée j'ai repris cet
été mais là j'ai arrêté dernièrement moi
je bois très peu je bois mettons le site
de faire une moyenne de mettons mes
consommations par semaine c'est
peut-être trop par semaine
je travaille beaucoup beaucoup trop je
sens pas beaucoup
la pression vos amis le monde dans des
sorties
mais en fait moi je fais de la musique
dans la vie puis c'est sûr que dans ce
domaine là euh
maintenant je pense que mettons la
moyenne de consommation pour le moment
plus élevé dans ce milieu-là dans le
reste
de la population là fac oui il y a une
pression tu mettons
mettons 3 c'est probablement dans mon
quotidien mais je te l'ai retourné
mettons en France un mois qui permet le
mettons on va au resto le soir on se
prend une bouteille de vin et puis il
fait que ça a augmenté mais de règle
générale je suis un peu l'exception à la
règle dans mon dans mon milieu là
qui boit pas puis qui se lève tôt le
lendemain aller courir son jogging puis
bon je me fais regarder à travers tes
pas vrai Rockstar je suis content de
vous avoir dans notre vie les gars
[Rires]
en général moi c'est pour ça qu'il
m'avait approché à la base c'est que je
te festif puis cache pas là
le petit milieu tu sais les gens ils
connaissent pas mais je veux dire
journalistique tout ça c'est clair quand
brainstorming pour leur documentaire la
boîte de prod qui s'appelle blime sont
dit kiki qui serait un bon porteur de
ballon puis honnêtement je suis pas mal
ça qui est un peu déçu parce qu'ils
m'ont fait de passer une batterie de
test pour voir je pense qu'il se
disaient chose d'un peu immersif c'est
un peu mon ma spécialité enfin qui
voulait je pense
qu'il y en avait un qui était
probablement en train de mourir d'une
cirrhose dans la communauté
journalistique c'est sûr que c'est lui
qui pensait finalement
je suis Top chef très déçu enfin qu'on
leur virer ça en en kitchcock
puis quand tu dis tu bois beaucoup que
ça représente moi comme un ado je bois
pas la semaine cette semaine je bois pas
j'ai plus je fais pas le shake j'aime
pas le goût de la bière moi j'aime pas
le goût de la boisson j'aime les faits
de la boisson effectivement c'est plus
pour le l'échapper la fin de semaine ça
me prend ma brosse hebdomadaire on
dirait une béquille pour fonctionner
puis dans ce temps-là
mettons
l'équivalent deux bouteilles de vin en
mode sol mettons un buveur de vin avec
un shooter par-ci par-là un petit joint
participer quinzaine de consommation
et puis là c'est moins pire qu'avant
parce que j'ai sur l'auteur intégré de
l'eau la consommation puis ça je le fais
pour de vrai puis on dirait que ça
puis-je aussi pris des trucs en chemin
une fois que tu as éteint le niveau
d'être chaud derrière mission accomplie
tandis qu'avant je pouvais je t'attends
que que la soirée est finie
aucun repère jusqu'à la fin du parte et
puis tout est le dernier parti puis là
maintenant quand je suis un peu chaud
derrière je me dis c'est mission
accomplie c'est ça le but c'est le
meilleur effet de ta soirée après ça le
départ des niaiseries
donc moi ce je m'en tiens à ça faut que
je fais je fais un effort mais tu sais
je suis très influençable puis si
j'arrive dans un bol mais je vois pas
partir le premier je vois pas ce que ce
que tu fais de pas boire pendant le
temps des fêtes pendant une longue
période bravo
la sauge en me proposait de faire le
mois d'être un ambassadeur du mois sans
alcool février j'ai dit non j'étais
transparent je suis pas capable je
serais pas capable de faire ça c'est pas
que j'avais pas de fan à relever le défi
du tout
la question maintenant d'avoir fait le
documentaire ça tu modifié tes habitudes
ou oui parce que
je bois sur autre surveillance
mais pour vrai au début j'allais SAQ
puis j'étais de la paranoïa mais j'ai
l'impression que le monde me checker
quasiment puis dans des soirées aussi tu
sais je pense à eux quand même
sensibiliser beaucoup de monde autour de
moi aussi je vois beaucoup plus d'eau
apparaît je vois beaucoup de sens alcool
apparaître que je voyais pas avant la
bière sans alcool jean sans alcool puis
ça je suis pas à cause de moi là mais je
veux dire je pense tout le monde a eu
chacun de son bord sa petite sa petite
introspection et moi aussi je l'ai eu
pour de vrai enfin qui était j'avoue que
j'ai pas moins de fan depuis que j'ai
slaqué que je bois moi avant je peux
boire deux trois fois le Vendredi Samedi
de couper ça parce que c'est des vrais
préoccupations de santé puis je rentre
du vieux j'ai 44 facté un lendemain de
veille c'est plus juste à la maison sur
la même veille donc le ratiophone versus
backlash de ma brosse s'est rendu c'est
pas passionné par rapport avant moi
j'étais capable c'est un marathonien
j'étais capable de brosser plusieurs
fois d'être totalement topshape avant de
double vie j'ai des affaires j'étais
capable de toute façon d'aller au centre
police le lendemain à 5h du matin mais
lever à 10h pour 9h pour aller au centre
police donc j'étais j'ai tenu ça des
années puis là m'a donné ça comme mon
corps me suivait plus faire ça se fait
tout seul un peu donc je bois moins oui
à cause de tout ça puis tu me fais pas
semblant par contre que je suis pas à
l'abri d'une bonne brosse en fin de
semaine
le corps est quand même bon pour envoyer
des messages à l'être humain mettons des
messages qu'on décide ou non de pas
recevoir si maintenant si tu as si tu es
déshydraté tu vas avoir soit tu vas
avoir besoin de bons stuff c'est pas
passé manger tu vas finir puis moi je me
rappelle quand j'ai arrêté pour la
première fois de boire l'année passée
mais je m'étais levé à l'emmène 20 j'ai
fait
c'est sûr que c'est un message qu'on
m'envoie le c'est comment je me sens
parce que de toutes les affaires que tu
peux faire que ce soit que tu fasses des
drogues tu fasses je veux dire des
ultras marathons que tu fasses n'importe
quoi un lendemain de veille moi c'est la
pire sensation genre de toutes les
lendemains de whatever que ce soit
l'activité sportive que ce soit d'autres
drogues de récréation que ce soit
whatever un lendemain je me suis dit
c'est sûr que si je me sens même
si ça va être débile l'effet que ça là
sur sur mon corps sur mon cerveau sur
toute le thé puis toi c'est un peu je
lisais un article je pense dans Le
Devoir qui disait que c'était un peu le
point de départ de ton truc c'est de
faire là le lendemain qu'est-ce qui se
passe si le tiens tout à fait ça a été
un bon moment où c'est un effet plus
psychologique donc quel est le stynésie
que j'ai dit que la soirée puis de
décider d'avoir des blackout ça c'est un
peu terrifiant
puis moi je suis un joyeux festif là je
suis pas un creepy
non plus j'ai pas parti je sais que je
suis pas en train d'insulter du monde de
vouloir me battre ou d'agresser du monde
mais quand même il y a rien de plus
épais qu'un trou dans une soirée où
est-ce que tu parles le dernier
avant c'était plus psychologique puis tu
es graduellement c'était physique moi
j'avais mal au poumon je fais aussi la
clope mais je fume juste quand je bois
enfin excessif dans ces vis-là de la
semaine j'ai pas fumé cette semaine mais
si je bois ben là je deviens
chainsmokers puis là je fais mais je
peux fumer un paquet dans une soirée là
je mets ici c'est l'été et puis on est
dehors effectivement j'ai mal partout là
je commence à être une cirrhose il y a
de la paranoïa puis aussi ben haute
déclicité que je passe
j'ai fait une tuerie dans un un innocent
accident de boisson un moment donné en
voyage
on voit tout ça puis tu dis plus tard
mais toi tu m'as là c'est très sexy
Thunder début d'épisode où c'est à
limite Darwin
ses amis ils vont demander à mon gars
m'ont donné ton Paillou il est mort de
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
c'est pas glorieux factice ça aussi ça
m'a donné un petit coup là
ma nouvelle obsession c'est ça s'appelle
le youberman Lab c'est un podcast enjoy
you Berman
son podcast sur l'alcool ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle parce que ça
fait un petit bout qui est sorti ça fait
longtemps que je le repousse parce que
le monde qui m'en parle m'en parle comme
étant genre un avant puis après
l'épisode sur l'alcool ok plein de gars
ça fait longtemps que je le repose puis
là tandis que là je suis en processus de
réarrêter de boire je l'ai écouté cette
semaine
puis c'est juste fou toutes les toutes
les aspects négatifs majeurs sur le long
terme que des comptes puis lui appelle
ça consommation chronique consommation
chronique comment qu'il définit c'est 7
à 14 consommations par semaine peu
importe comment tu le distribues fait
c'est comme on disait 14 le samedi ou
bien 1 à 2 verres une à deux
consommations par semaine
le dommage déjà le dommage cellulaire au
cerveau et
de mesurer je pense que tu en parles
justement dans le documentaire c'est
quoi que tu as frappé quand tu as abordé
l'aspect santé en premier dans
exactement ça l'impact sur le cerveau
moi c'était le ton podcast 7 à 14
consommation
beaucoup de monde boit au-delà
énormément [__] les gens
combien tu bois tout le monde met ça à
la pêche en général mais c'est à 14
c'est pas fou puis quand tu vois puis
c'était ça quand on a rencontré c'est un
neurologue puis qui nous a expliqué que
quand tu rentres dans les
recommandations les anciennes
recommandations ils viennent des updes
d'été de cet instant c'était une
quinzaine de consommation pour les
hommes par semaine 0-15 par semaine
si tu étais là dedans l'impact sur ton
cerveau à long terme c'était dévastateur
et plus plus avec lui le même si j'ai
rien là puis j'ai une bonne mémoire il
me disait tout si tu continues sur cette
belle lancée là tu vois ton cerveau puis
il y avait des graphiques très très dans
ta face là dessus puis
j'ai même rencontré un de ces patients
qui étaient là qui était pas si vieux
que ça il y avait une soixantaine
d'années ils sont surnom son surnom
c'est grave soif
mais lui c'était
je vous laisse tirer vos propres
conclusions lui disait c'était pas le
c'était pas le Gigon là le pilier de
taverne c'était le godeparté du coin qui
était tout à l'heure qui repartait ces
deux jambes puis c'était moi là puis
Jedi
bien l'alcool tout est c'est lui mais
c'est toi mais encore je me voyais dans
ce cas-là puis lui là il fait juste les
numéros 5 mots random pamplemousse
brocheuse tout ça puis il dit répète-moi
tout de suite après le gars pas capable
en tout puis l'autre il faisait des
petits exercices de même puis sur le
cerveau à haute à 40 ans moi ça va mais
tu es quand tu penses 50 60 la mémoire
puis déjà moi je terrorisé par ça parce
que je pense que c'est la pire à faire
qui peut arriver là de de commencer à
oublier ta vie précoce à cause de la
boisson mettons dans 60 ans tu tu
reconnais plus tes quêtes sont pas si
bien que ça ta blonde c'était puis ça ça
m'a un peu un petit peu terrorisé c'est
fou parce que c'est en fait l'être
humain on a juste une un organe de
de
penser que des actions que tu prends
jeunes puis yoberman explique que plus
tes jeunes puisque commencent à boire de
cette phrase tu commences à être un
buveur chronique dans ces années-là
de développer soit la police ou de créer
des problèmes pour plus tarder des
décisions tu prends quand tu es vraiment
jeune ils peuvent venir te rechercher
60 ans il t'en reste des belles années
c'était encore toute là c'est ça
un peu de 4 x 60 ans tu vis le moment
présent puis tu dis pas grave je vois
tellement avoir de fun que plus tard
mettez leur vieillissant tu fais bon
mettons mourir à 53 ans puis que les
gens mais funérailles c'est genre c'est
un institutrice
de merde
conscience de ça vieillissant puis moi
je suis exactement là-dedans
développe pas si longtemps que ça même
quand j'avais des kit jeunes je sais
quand même moi j'ai du fun mais que des
rond du fun avec puis mon message à eux
c'est vis ta vie comme s'il y a pas de
lendemain puis
si c'est tout ça finit jeune mais que tu
as du fun Yasser puis là on vieillissant
finalement
75 ans puis d'aller euh
oui mais de faire des voyages
entre vois que ça se peut mais j'ai pas
pris les moyens pour la date moi je me
suis tout a été dans l'excès puis ça
fait depuis
44 dauphin depuis 16 ans que je suis lui
qui finit les qui clause les parties
toutes les amis qui coûteraient ça ils
seront d'accord
ils ont 20 ans de moins que moi puis
c'est ça c'est c'est je sais pas exprès
je suis faite comme ça
qui est chimiquement fait pour la fête
dans un dans une tonne mais je me sens
comme ça moi tu sais je
des gens qui ont un certain gêne que
sous l'effet de l'alcool souvent mettons
tu vas prendre un verre ça va comme un
peu teinquer te réveiller tu vas être
plus sociable plus
plus plus de parties finalement piquer
après souvent la majorité des gens
prennent plusieurs consommations les
vont commencer à s'endormir ils vont
commencer à être moins moitié mais
certaines personnes plus ils boit juste
plus en forme puis dit ces gens-là c'est
les gens qui sont le plus subtiles de
développer des problèmes d'alcoolisme
justement parce que
l'alcool pour eux un effet
euphorisant plus que la majorité des
gens c'est pas une addiction c'est une
malédiction c'est pas trop mais tu sais
moi j'en connais du monde qui boit ils
deviennent un peu plus de ta situation
renfermée mauvais violent mais tu es moi
j'ai jamais eu ça et puis il faut je
fasse attention justement à cause de ça
parce que j'ai pas de c'est pas associé
à des mauvaises expériences des des
textes associés vraiment juste au
plaisir moi enfin que c'était moi de
trouver des moyens de me calmer
là-dessus puis le défi c'est de trouver
d'autres manières ça je te demandais
tantôt ou à toi comment tu fais pour
prendre pour moi j'associe alcool à
plaisir puis on dirait que en dehors de
ça je sais pas je vois pas monter le
mont Saint-Hilaire le peinture que les
fin de semaine j'ai pas un gars plein
air j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai j'aime beaucoup
le karaoké c'est très associé la boisson
facture trouver ça serait un objectif
pour me trouver des intérêts qui ont qui
implique aucune consommation d'alcool
je veux dire l'alcool c'est souvent
imbriqué avec social mettons événement
social souper fête
puis c'est même événements social là si
tu enlèves l'alcool mettons dans
l'alcool le tu essayes
mais j'ai moins de fun ça m'a donné mais
j'aime ça
avoir du français
les les partenaires dans vos entourage
si décide de pas boire dans un parreté
mais c'était il y en a des gens plus
tranquilles que si boit pas trop mais
moi si je devais nous apporter puis que
je suis tranquille je bois pas
comment ça va dessus
c'est de ma faute c'est juste moi
blooming des années d'être très très
lourde en boisson tu sais j'ai des amis
moi que je les gossais tout le temps
quand ils partaient les premiers
à 2h du matin n'importe où à moi le
fatiguant que je pensais
me rappeler à la dure je pense à une en
particulier que moto monastique
totalement
l'idée de l'alcool je veux dire il y a
une raison pour qu'on en prenne malgré
le fait que le lendemain on s'entre ça
change notre état puis ça nous a dit ça
nous fait
peu importe la raison il y en a que ça
fait des lier la langue il y en a que ça
fait enlever l'anxiété il y en a pour
plein de raisons d'habitude d'avoir du
fun essentiellement après ça si tu en
prends pour oublier
de la misère de ta vie à chaque jour ça
c'est vraiment un autre histoire mais il
y a quand même de quoi pour les choses
qui viennent modifier notre état tu sais
il y a quelque chose que le sans alcool
peut pas produire quelque chose qui est
d'aller dans un souper entre amis peut
pas générer tu sais il y a comme
l'idée de dire maintenant on sait tout
ça maintenant maintenant on sait tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça tu sais
c'est quoi la c'est quoi qu'on fait en
fait juste dire ben c'est fini ou bien
on fait dire c'est quoi
l'avenue je pense c'est ça la question
principale qui demeure après après tout
seul il y a des pompes et des comptes
mais c'est juste que j'ai l'impression
que les contre en fait ont laissé
à part le plaisir puis genre quelques
études qui disent que mettons pour le
coeur ça peut être bon de
consommer de ce que j'ai lu le titre de
consommer de cette façon faible à
modérer mais sinon sur toutes les
aspects restent de cancer de plein de
cancer mémoire anxiété dépression tout
ça c'est démontré que négatif pour
justement le positif qui est à votre
femme qui est un positif je veux dire
qui est quand même assez positif quand
même positif aussi sauf que prendre une
décision éclairée de pour les comptes il
faut quand même les connaître chose que
on discute pas tant que ça en parle
souvent d'un documentaire il y a plein
de choses c'est qui fait que
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le documentaire il mettait
un peu les Spotlight sur ses problèmes
là j'avoue que on était dû parce que
c'est un bon lien la cigarette
quelqu'un qui fume aujourd'hui encore il
peut pas dire qu'il y ait pas courant
les méfaits de la cigarette
par jour aujourd'hui mettons de votre
ordre de notre thé jeune
tu prends la décision consciente
ça va peut-être pas tuer mais on a toute
la grammaire à part que fumée toute sa
vie puis qui est pas mort de ça oui mais
dans tous les sérieusement qui ont fait
toutes les guerres possibles Imaginales
qui ont aucun syndrome post-traumatique
qui vivent le en tout cas c'est la même
affaire il va en avoir des des brasseurs
euh ben quelques mois là les mineurs je
tenais une réunion des AA pour faire je
l'entendre ces gens-là sur les
recommandations tout ça c'est pas des
c'est pour moi je serai je serai la
petite bière là ça m'arrive j'ai même
pas fait exprès non mais je serai là tu
sais c'est des des des gros
consommateurs à tous les jours à bout
des grosses quantités c'est là tous les
jours c'est ça je suis capable de mais
en même temps on le sait là aujourd'hui
il est avec les nouvelles études donc tu
sais que c'est lié à cette cancers tu
sais que c'est pas bon pour ta mémoire
tu sais que c'est pas bon pour les packs
sur la santé mentale tu vois toutes les
les gens qui sont en charge toutes les
histoires d'un conduite sexuelle avait
je dis pas que l'alcool mène à ça mais
c'est c'est c'est souvent dénominateur
commun
c'est pas bon le bois là c'est pas du du
punch aux fruits il fait santé c'est
c'est pas bon c'est un poids c'est un
c'est un poison pas tout à l'heure le
docteur dans on va dire c'est bon pour
le coeur peut-être mais c'est pas bon
pour plein d'autres à faire une fois que
tu sais ça
tu veux continuer à boire et puis moi je
suis pas en train de dire au monde de
témoin je veux pas non plus qu'il y ait
des des des fois nécrosées ces
bouteilles de vin comme ça cigarettes je
veux pas tant que ça je veux pas qu'on
soit plus aseptisé qu'on est là ce qu'on
voulait c'est partager une information
que maintenant si les gens le savent
j'avais l'impression que tout le monde
savait pas trop ça puis banalisé on
cachait pas à quel point c'était nocif
l'alcool une fois que les gens le savent
comme la cigarette comme le pote ben là
tout le monde est déjà adultes la vie
est courte c'est c'est ton écharpe à toi
ta becquis une limite peut-être que l'on
peut philosopher sur pourquoi boire la
fuite sûremente que c'est un peu une
béquille pour Ben du monde mais moi
c'est une béquille il y en a que c'est
le jogging il y en a que c'est c'est
l'entraînement extrême ben moi c'est
dans ma petite brosse Hebdo puis il y a
des pires que d'autres par contre des
béquilles oui il y en a des pays en même
temps j'aimerais mieux être je pense que
tous les humains aimeraient ça être
exemples de becking c'est d'être 100%
des personnes dépendantes d'absolument
rien mais je suis pas là dans mon
processus de vie peut-être un jour
j’aspect devenir ce Jedi qui que je
domine aucun désir aucun besoin non puis
que je contrôle tout mais là
présentement
pour moi c'est un peu réconfortant de me
dire j'ai une semaine de merde ou j'ai
une grosse semaine le fun je vais
célébrer j'ai une semaine de Marne je
vais revenir pour passer à autre chose
c'est sécurisant c'est ça mon combat
peut-être qu'il y a un moment donné
d'être capable de me dire je vais aller
prendre une marche telle place ou
jogging ou faire whatever Cup ça va
avoir le même effet euphorisant ou mais
je suis pas là
un autre effet Florizarre mais c'est pas
le même
peut-être ça arrive plus tard
tu te lèves un matin tu fais bon mais ma
vie de bon parc animal je peux puncher
ma carte tu sais savoir si on a tous été
dans des bars où tu avais le la personne
de 63 ans tu dis pas que ça à la côte
c'est un petit peu triste le fait que
peut-être ça se fait tout seul ça fait
un moment donné d'être
le resta de karaoké des années captives
de 60 ans qui va là puis je voudrais pas
non plus être la caricature toute
l'impression que l'alcool pourrait
mettons dans le futur prendre une genre
de même trajectoire si on veut que la
cigarette qui a une certaine époque les
effets négatifs de la cigarette on le
savait pas vraiment même que
certains avancés que c'était bon c'est
pas mal
maintenant des athlètes du Tour de
France avec une cigarette avec une top
dans le maillot jaune puis une taupe
Villeneuve qui était je sais pas si vous
avez vu ça mais ça fait pas à 97 là ça
me fait triper tu m'as pas vous avez
quel âge mais bref Jacques Villeneuve là
ok c'est bon ok vous êtes juste mieux
conserver dans les 30 quelque chose
il faisait c'était player son puis
Hotmail m'a donné je pense mais player
c'était son commanditeur affectés
ça partout moi je mets au cégep là on
avait quand même un prof couple le filo
qui nous donnait le évidemment qui me
donnait l'option de fumer dans notre
dans notre classe là et oui c'est ça
juste cette semaine j'ai vu des articles
sur les débats est-ce qu'on devrait
boire la télé
aujourd'hui c'est un no brainer que tu
vas pas fumer c'est un plateau de télé
c'est comme quelqu'un ferait ça on
ferait c'est un malade
l'eau ça boit cette photo
là ça boit c'est complètement accepté
quand mêmement normal je penses-tu que
dans 30 ans regardez ça puis on va dire
une certaine époque ça buvait pas tout
télé
puis je veux pas que ça parce que je
trouve faut pas mélanger la cigarette
même si c'est pas bon baisse la
cigarette c'est pas bon de chez pas bon
là tandis que l'alcool il y a 85 % du
monde qui qui boit dans la société ça
touche c'est ratissent c'est beaucoup
plus grand public que la cigarette ou le
pote tactile
c'est c'est une substance c'est pas une
c'est pas bon mais c'est consommé par
une grosse majorité de monde enfin que
c'est
pas bon même qu'on le fait tout mais on
on l'accepte seulement bah le fait de le
banaliser peut-être moins passe
peut-être un peu mieux que ça limite top
et puis j'avoue que moi en tant que
fumeur social les gens qui fument dans
les films où tu écoutes Mad Men ou des
trucs
là c'est quoi c'est le truc de Xavier
Dolan la nuit ou laurier s'est réveillé
c'est ça il y avait des scènes c'est les
c'est dans le passé puis tout le monde
fume puisque je veux dire c'est c'est ça
ajoute ça dans ton cerveau je sais pas
si ça ferait la même chose pour
quelqu'un qui est cassé d'arrêter
l'alcool mais moi j'ai pas ce même
trigger là quand je vois du monde boire
sur un plateau
pendant université parce que j'ai écouté
Californication les 8 saisons d'affilée
puis tu sais incubé le personnage
principal tout le temps en train de
fumer puis boire genre du rhum ou du
whisky
puis j'ai fumé c'était le genre moi j'ai
jamais fumé je fais de la semaine
cool à s'allumer une top et à fumer puis
j'arrête en
pitié évidemment tu sens pas la
cigarette comme pas toute l'aspect un
peu repoussant la cigarette là il y a
juste un tellement cool j'ai fumé
pendant l'été j'ai fait mourir là
David duchovni
j'ai l'impression quand j'ai déjà
entendu deux trois entrevues sur ce
débat là récemment sur l'alcool sur les
plateaux que j'ai l'impression que ça va
se faire aussi parce que c'est vrai que
là c'est comme un peu il y a ouvert la
machine on est passé de pas vraiment
d'alcool c'est peut-être à Tout le monde
en parle il y en avait d'un titre mais
là toutes les choses maintenant intègre
un bon vieux mixologue qui arrive qui te
fait deux trois affaires afin lire Salut
Bonjour le matin il est tôt là comme la
portion mixologue de la semaine je pense
qu'on est rendu loin là-dedans puis un
petit côté ça fait comme intello non
d'un coup bourgeois puis c'est toute la
perception aussi c'est dit tu dis
mettons à quelqu'un que tu prends ton
petit verre de blanc tous les soirs
c'est comme chic tu imagines qui coûte
du Chopin des enfants ils font leur
devoir l'un sur le stool en avant c'est
c'est chic un peu tu dis je fais ma
toits soir un BAT en dessous de la hotte
c'est moins
droguer
c'est la même craft et au final c'est
juste parce que là l'alcool et c'est ça
parce que l'effet c'est ça qu'on réalise
maintenant c'est que l'effet de l'alcool
est aussi pire sinon pire que l'effet
d'une cigarette c'est la drogue la plus
excuse-moi il paraît que c'est la drogue
la plus nocive plus que l'héroïne c'est
l'alcool puis la cigarette tout ça c'est
des grosses drogues là dans le fond
qu'on banalise un peu dis-moi mettons en
termes de coup voilà la société mettons
en santé ou c'est de loin et l'alcool
c'est qui coûte le plus cher la société
ben oui parce que c'est consommé par
tellement de monde puis on a une fausse
perception viande vache à lait avec la
SAQ ça c'est quelque chose que nous on a
appris dans notre recherche pour le
documentaire c'est que quand tu voyais
dans la pandémie les line-up tu dis
l'argent rentre comme de l'eau à la SAQ
puis tu sais c'est l'impression que tu
vas un peu poison parce que tu finances
un paquet d'affaires avec cet argent-là
le prix du monde qui vient voir à
l'hôpital c'est ça qui était c'était fou
on paye plus dans le fond en coups
sociaux de santé de problématique
judiciaire toutes ces coups là c'est
dépenses là je vais pas vous donner
n'importe quel chiffre mais je pense que
la SEQ par année ramène net de dividende
net là un point 2 milliards qui font de
l'argent ils payent leur staff il y a
beaucoup d'employés puis il revient un
point 2 milliards dans les poches de
l'état que tu qui creuserait distribué
au Québec puis les coups je pense que
c'est à peu près 4 milliards par année
en coup de santé bon pas juste l'alcool
mais tiens mettons que tu tu rentres à
l'hôpital tu as une cour morbidité mais
que l'alcool est impliqué un accident à
cause de la boisson un crime à cause de
la boisson un accident de chat toutes
coup là c'est beaucoup plus que ce que
ça nous rapporte facté dans le fond
c'est pas payant là d'avoir un monopole
d'État de l'alcool présentement ça
serait pas mieux d'avoir privatisé
partout mais il faut juste que les gens
comprennent que c'est pas une vache à
laitue et en fait je pense que
effectivement c'est quand même mieux moi
j'ai quand même plus confiance que ce
soit entre les mains du gouvernement
quand les mains de compagnie Privée qui
vont qui vont vouloir voir le plus de
profit possible mais c'est sûr que les
techniques d'instruments pour le volant
documentaire si je veux dire s'apparente
à des copains privés dans le sens que
c'est l'objectif numéro 1 c'est de faire
du profit puis la prévention puis le
sensibilisation c'est pas dans leur
mandat c'est que c'est oui c'est
sécurisant que le gouvernement s'en
occupe mais c'est pas le ministère de la
Santé qui s'en occupe c'est le ministre
des Finances lui il a mis c'est pas le
ministère des Finances et le ministre
des Finances donc là lui le ministre des
Finances qui est le boss de la SAQ il
donne le mandat à la SA devant de
l'alcool mais quand que ça vient des
finances la mission de SAQ c'est de
faire du cash tu donnes un mandat
commercial avec lui la prévention le
ministre des Finances se pose pas toutes
dans
son quartier de ça il pèse
la prévention c'est pas leur job non
plus ils vont dire quand tu leur
demandes oui on insiste pas les gens à
boire on met pas de la des bouteilles à
me répondre ça là on met pas des
bouteilles dans leur panier merci
quasiment sûr tellement c'est attrayant
tellement c'est facile tellement c'est
genre tu rentres là tu as l'impression
d'être dans un shop de Noël mais là ils
ont confié le mandat de faire la
prévention à et du calcule qui est un
organisme privé qui est pas encore que
le gouvernement ça aussi c'est un autre
problème de perception moi j'ai tout un
eu l'impression ça fait 20 ans que je
suis journaliste j'ai appelé combien de
fois du calcule en pensant que c'était
le le l'outil de promotion de prévention
du gouvernement
c'est pas ça du tout
une demi-heure que je parlais une heure
que parler avec Nicole en arrière puis
que qui m'a dit que c'est gouvernemental
le ministre des Finances pour le
monopole moi j'étais surpris de voir
personne savait ça ou presque moi je le
savais parce que justement on me l'avait
déjà dit mais je pense pas que votre âge
savait ça puis ça fait pas longtemps que
c'est ça puis là dans mon entourage
quand on demandait le le les gens
pensaient que c'était la rigidité des
alcools et des jeux j'ai même eu le
tourisme tu sais je les ai tout entendu
mais les finances il y a pas tant de
monde que ceux qui savent je dis pas
qu'il cache mais je pense qu'on a une
méconnaissance quand même de de comment
ça fonctionne l'alcool au Québec
puis justement pendant le sujet de du
calcul
on a cette idée là
deuxièmement quand on se rend quand on
se penche pour avoir un documentaire
encore une fois sur c'est quoi être
calcule c'est qui du calcule on se rend
compte que des gens sur le CEA de
organisme de toutes sortes de domaines
dont des gens du domaine des alcools des
producteurs bah il y a beaucoup de monde
de l'industrie de l'alcool qui sont sur
le ce il y a pas personne que la
majorité dans cette ça sera jamais
quelqu'un non plus d'industrie qui est
le président du CE il y a comme quelques
règles établis quand même des personnes
qui sont là pour faire ce qui travaille
dans des groupes de de
c'est pas des médecins mais c'est du
monde qui sont plus dans la la voyante
un organisme comme Jean Lapointe tout ça
des fondations qui sont qui sont dans la
sensibilisation tout ça de l'alcool
juste en train de
scraper un peu leur définition de tâches
mais il y a des gens qui sont là pour
les bonnes raisons qui sont là dans la
prévention autour de la table mais quand
même beaucoup de monde de l'industrie
c'est financer à zéro de dollar par le
gouvernement et c'est financé par
l'industrie de l'alcool donc l'industrie
de l'alcool a créé du calcule il y a 30
ans et la finance à toutes les années
donc
c'est c'est compliqué pourquoi on n'a
jamais eu ces informations là facilement
accessibles à nous mettons
sur leur site mais c'est sûr qu'on met
pas ça de l'avant dans les campagnes on
parle tout le temps de modération on
parle pas de cancer on parle de deux
consommations trois consommations
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut se dire que
ceci explique cela moi j'ai la quasiment
d'un complotiste de juste soulever ça en
entrevue mais dans le fond ça donne une
apparence un peu de conflit d'intérêt
puis ben veut pas mais c'est à eux aussi
de peut-être rebrander leur image pour
rester de montrer que non non ils sont
là pour les bonnes raisons parce que il
faut quand même leur rendre ce qui leur
appartient c'est grâce à eux que le
slogan la modération bien meilleur coup
s'est rendu tout le monde le connaît
sauf le gars là tout le monde enfin qui
ont réussi à faire ça mais il faut que
tu comprends qui contrôle la patente qui
est d'être autour de la table du CEA ils
veulent pas non plus que t'arrête
complètement de bois c'est c'est là de
leur peintre là-bas enfin qui veulent
oui faire la prévention oui je pense pas
que du calcaire son machiavélique
le plus de monde alcoolique possible
puis il se réjouissent pas de ça je
pense qu'ils veulent ils ont raison dit
que la majorité du monde c'est bon puis
boit correctement puisqu'il y a pas de
problème mais le fait de tout a pelleter
les problèmes sur une minorité d'en
faire un problème individuel au lieu de
le voir comme un problème collectif
c'est à mon sens c'est pas correct c'est
un problème parce que c'est comme si
c'est comme le jeu là pour faire un
parallèle on parle jamais de problème
collectif de jeu on se dédouane en
disant oh il y a une coupe il y a une
coupe de joueurs des machines à sous
mais la majorité des gens jouent pour la
femme va dans un bar puis regarde les
gens l'autre vidéo tu vois pas beaucoup
de plaisir dans ces phases là au casino
personne a du fun mais tu vois des
pubstone casino je suis spéciale encore
mais c'était tout le monde du monde avec
des belles dents blanches qui ont du fun
puis qui qui joue l'un des campagnes de
pub jouer pour le fun mais c'est grave
personne
avec une hypocrisie derrière ça un peu
l'habitude de même chose pour l'alcool
de dire tout taxe le problème de
quelques alcooliques qui l'ont échappé
mais dans le fond tu
tues à 84 % de la population il devrait
avoir une responsabilité qui vient avec
surtout quand tu sais maintenant qu'un
paquet de cancer association à ça que ça
prendrait puissance pour moi qui le dit
c'est les intervenants qui sont calés
là-dedans qui font qui sont dans le
documentaire ça prendrait une espèce de
chien de garde complètement indépendant
entre la population gouvernement puis à
l'heure actuelle il existe pas ce chien
garde là au Québec il existe partout au
Canada il y a il existe ailleurs mais
ici on l'a pas cette espèce de non plus
de contact direct avec le gouvernement
pour lever un flingue quand tu étais
il y en a un comité de vigilance qui
appelle donc ça ça veut dire que c'est
des gens qui sont du milieu de la santé
puis il y a d'autres qui trouvent que ça
a pas ça a pas de bon sens
pour telle telle raison mais ils peuvent
appeler directement le ministre pour
dire ça ça a pas de bon sens mais c'est
bizarre qu'il y a pas ça pour l'alcool
alors que c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de consommateurs
faudrait m'expliquer puis on veut pas ça
mais faudrait juste qu'il soit
conséquent pourquoi la sqdc c'est un peu
à stade tu rentres tu es un gars de
sécurité
tu t'en vas là tu il y a pas de spéciaux
il y a pas de promotion il y a pas
d'annonce à télé il y a pas de
dégustation il y a rien de ça ça puis la
même ministère gère la sqdc la sécu tu
rentres à la SAQ c'est c'est Walmart là
c'est c'est des dégustations des ça va
bien des rabais une carte une carte de
fidélité tu fais des rabais à qui tu
fais des spéciaux à qui des promotions à
qui tu te
tournesol tu compétition pourquoi tu
fais une promotion c'est toi le monopole
pour que tu as tout fait un deal à nous
autres pour impliquer les gens plus
consommés
je comprends il faudrait m'expliquer la
logique de rabais de promotion dans un
monopole tu sais si le temps de tous
pour deux vendeurs de souliers puis il y
en a qui fait des spéciaux parce que il
veut faire mal à l'autre il était je
sais pas mais là dans un monopole ça
comme pas de dans le documentaire
c'est comme une question de j'attends
l'inventaire avec
j'ai vraiment beaucoup d'une bouteille
il faut que je les passe mais un gros
rabais on sort ce type mais faudrait
tout expliquer ça parce que les gens
sont pas imbécile il faut faudrait être
plus transparent peut-être là-dessus
pour que les gens comprennent bien
comment ça fonctionne mais je dirais ce
que le fait de faire un rabbit souvent
avant de plus de gens qui vont boire le
thé au final ben oui c'est au final même
si la majorité de la population consomme
de façon responsable plus souvent
l'alcool plus il y a des gens qui vont
des problèmes d'alcool c'est juste
logique
plutôt de bouteilles qui sort plutôt
d'alcoolique que tu produis dans ta
société puis
en le disant j'ai comme réalisé à quel
point c'était un non-sens une carte
fidélité c'est fou là c'est comme pour
t'encourager à revenir encore
casseralité pour une substance qui crée
une dépendance
c'est fou là
il y avait une carte
puis si tu le fais pour l'alcool il
fallait pour le pour le pote d'abord tu
étais la même tu es la même tu es la
même compagnie là que fait le fais-moi
des rabais fais-moi des dégustations on
fait moitié je veux dire fais-moi des
spéciaux pourquoi puis pourquoi c'est
caché tout ça parce que dans la tête du
monde le pote c'est mal puis l'alcool
c'est cool l'actrice c'est un jeu là
aussi peut-être que la puis en même
temps je dis ça puis je voudrais pas que
tu rentres à la sécu comme à la sqdc
avec quelqu'un qui check ta carte voir
la bonne personne puis je veux pas ça tu
sais je je on préférerait avoir une
excuse décès plus attrayante
pourquoi autant de monde vont sur les
dans les communautés taxton parce que
les autres c'est c'est c'est très sur le
modèle de chacune tu as des gens qui
t'accompagnent moi je suis jamais allé
évidemment mais j'ai entendu dire que
c'était comme ça que ça fonctionne
on parlait de la comparaison avec la
cigarette mettons puis
quand tu disais que il y a vraiment plus
c'est l'alcool avec beaucoup plus de
monde que la cigarette pouvait en
affecter même avant
il y a vraiment on dirait un enjeu quand
on se met à parler de tous les problèmes
liés à l'alcool avec la grosseur de ce
domaine là parce qu'on dirait que c'est
démesuré à quel point c'est c'est énorme
le thé juste les tu regardes le super
ball par exemple c'est évidemment ça
c'est comme le comble de du truc là mais
un spot au Superbowl je pense tu es
comme 30 secondes ça va faire comme 15
millions le pisser juste baudouiner
c'est juste des compagnies d'alcool qui
prennent ces spots là c'est tellement
gros
qu'on dirait que aussi gros le switch de
couper la cigarette et nous on
était conscient on était assez vieux
pour être conscient du moment où est-ce
que le progressivement c'est quand même
qui est plus d'un resto plus d'un avion
plus d'un resto à 8 mètres
on était assez vieux pour voir ce
changement là qui devait être quand même
massif à l'époque
mais on dirait
de la résistance il y avait de la
résistance on fait pareil ça peut être
facile mais on dirait que c'est encore
tellement plus gros que j'ai de la
misère à voir comment même à la lumière
de ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui on va être
capable de surmonter un Goliath
monétaire aussi grand on va tout vivre
ça par contre ça va se faire un moment
donné mais j'avoue que c'est mais aussi
que sa coquine tout le temps au sport
puis tout ça peut-être qu'à un moment
donné puis on veut tout ça il faut aussi
collectivement se demander ça moi je
trouve ça très à cette idée là qu'on
évacue tout seul une cigarette ça
tombait dans le sens à un moment donné
quand tout le monde s'entend c'est je
pense que tu peux pas dire aux gens sur
25 cigarettes fumes en trois tu es
correct puis c'est un peu ça qui font
que l'alcool de dire tu peux avoir deux
trois par jour mais facture à un moment
donné
c'est des bonnes questions puis là c'est
payant il y a de l'argent mais en même
temps le lien alcool sport
rendu naturel
sauf qu'en même temps mettons si tu
prends toute la
musique ou juste au Québec
fondamentalement le mettons le nous la
Nouvelle Vague de microbrasseries puis
toute l'argent que ça génère puis
l'espèce de d'argent aussi pour le
tourisme largeur pour euh
des PME qui qui fonctionne c'est que
c'est tout ça aussi là au-delà de juste
comme la pub puis il a les acheter ça au
Couche-Tard mais tu as raison que ça va
être un autre chantier démesuré parce
que là il y a tellement plus de buveurs
c'est tellement plus associé je pense
pas
[Musique]
je sais même pas on dirait que ça fait
du sens quand même que tu annonces un
show c'est que de la bière annonce des
choses c'est correct le sport c'est
aussi organique ça mais bon tu dis les
gens qui consomment l'alcool à la maison
ça c'est un peu le cliché tout le temps
aussi là les annonces de bière pendant
super basses c'est classique
on dirait que c'est
énorme c'est
vertigineux quasiment une petite
révolution qui se passe ou là il y a un
buzz parce qu'il y a eu une coupe
d'affaires puis dans dans trois mois tu
vas même écouter cet épisode là ou dans
6 mois tu vas faire et bah ça c'était un
peu périmé là c'était dans le boss que
l'on se pose des questions sur l'alcool
puis finalement on est pas ça d'autre
chose à cause que on veut pas arrêter de
boire c'est ça
on a de l'air en croisade du bricoles
moi j'ai beaucoup mais je bois quand
même puis tu bois aussi
du jour au lendemain c'est un changement
une grosse industrie petit mettons
l'entreprise familiale de microbrasseurs
qui font ce qu'ils porter ça à bout de
bras puis qui sont passionnés de bière
puis qui veulent créer des produits qui
sont le fun je veux dire c'est pas c'est
pas les autres les courses de tous les
problèmes de la société et puis
c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup de monde
qui tout le monde travaille en
restauration dans les bars je dirais qui
justement qui sont pour producteurs
d'alcool je dirais c'est pas du mauvais
monde on a fait vivre pleinement
l'alcool puis les brasseurs la famille
de brasseurs qui fait bien son produit
puis qui est fier il se dit pas je vois
vendre ça je vois produire des
alcooliques il y aimerait se tomber sur
des connaisseurs déjà précis je respecte
ça énormément puis tu sais c'est ça je
veux pas jouer au curé non plus moi avec
tout ça mais il y a une chose qui est
intéressante par exemple c'est que si
mettons les recommandations de et du
calcule qui était deux par jour 10 par
semaine trois par jour 15 par semaine
c'est basé sur un modèle où est-ce que
une personne avec qui tu t'entretien
dans ton podcast
l'ancien patron de l'alcool Hubert Sassy
c'est ça qui dit que selon selon les
études ont selon son graphique les gens
qui consomment de manière faible à
modérer un espérance de vie supérieure
aux gens qui consomment pas du tout et
supérieur évidemment aux gens qui
consomment beaucoup et comme un genre de
Sweet Spot dans lequel tu veux en
guillemets trouver qui serait préférable
donc selon eux selon ce graphique là
sont ces études-là jusqu'au bout de les
données viennent ça serait ça serait ça
serait de consommation quelques verres
par semaine ce serait le Best mais de
plus en plus on dirait les données les
nouvelles données qui sort en tout cas
souvent tu mettais justement dans le
podcast de
youberman qui fait la liste exhaustive
en fait des effets de l'alcool sur la
santé puis de l'effet même de un verre
va avoir sur les qualités de ton sommeil
directement après quelques verres par
semaine sur comment tu vas sécréter des
hormones de stress sur la dépression ce
petit puis lui vraiment son message de
dire le Best c'est zéro le Best pas de
trop la baisse c'est 0 2 3 c'est pire
que 0 mais c'est mieux que c'est 7 etc
puis c'est plus tu bois piercer moins de
bois mieux c'est que là on est plus dans
le dans une coupe correcte c'est même
bon c'est le moins possible si tu peux
zéro c'est le best avec le si on va là
puis si on accepte que c'est ces données
là
qui sont mettons scientifiquement
approuvés par la majorité mettons puis
que si c'est ça les vrais les bonnes
données ça change complètement parce que
là on peut plus on peut plus ranger
derrière la modération c'est
l'abstinence de bien meilleure goût puis
sinon au pire la modération
date de 2011 avec la littérature
scientifique de ces années-là ce qu'on
avait moins creusé cancer tout ça là
aujourd'hui là on sait on sait que c'est
en cause de tout ça c'est comme si tu
prends je reviens avec mon exemple de
fumer tu dis fume une clope c'est moins
pire que d'en fumée 8 c'est sûr moins
c'est mieux mais si tu fais une clope
c'est pas bon pareil là ça reste si une
cigarette pleine de de cochonneries mais
c'est moins épais que c'était un film 24
mais c'est la même affaire l'alcool
c'est pas bon là il y a un statuer ça
maintenant tu disais si on est rendu à
l'admettre ou bien
si on veut on
veut aller plus loin dans des campagnes
dans les shopping mais là au moins on
met ça ça établi c'est des études quand
même assez sérieuse comme de l'an 7 tout
ça évidemment tu vois tout le temps
trouver quelqu'un qui sera pas d'accord
avec ça un médecin qui est il y en avait
un récemment qui était comme oui mais
c'est prouvé que c'est bon pour le cœur
euh bah oui il y a sûrement raison il
s'est appuyer sur plein d'études qui dit
qu'un verre de rouge c'est pas mauvais
pour le cas fin mais c'est peut-être bon
pour le cas mais c'est pas bon pour ça
c'est pas bon pour la fois c'est pas bon
pour le plein d'autres affaires c'est
factice ça s'annule à quelque part en
fait au moins la communauté scientifique
s'entend pour dire l'alcool c'est pas
bon pour ta santé point donc ça c'est la
nouvelle la nouvelle réalité
d'aujourd'hui c'était le cas avant mais
on on en faisait pas été tant que ça je
dis pas qu'on le cachait on n'était pas
ça avancé maintenant une fois qu'on est
établi ça ben on peut rendu là les gens
ils sont quand même assez libre de faire
ce qu'ils veulent avec en toute
connaissance de cause mais je suis
content moi qu'on soit sorti d'un
chiffre de
sécuritaire pour la santé ou bonne pour
la santé tubes c'est pas bon de la colle
là
mais
l'organisme que
que
si c'est quoi ça c'est le Centre
canadien sur la dépendance et l'usage de
substances ça c'est un comité d'experts
qui eux donnent leur directive il y a
que ça leur repère il envoie ça à Santé
Canada selon eux avec les études qui ont
c'est un groupe de recherche qui
travaille juste là-dessus pour pour
l'alcool et autres ils disent en
fonction de tout ce qu'il est partout
l'interaction scientifique voici en
fonction des risques le seuil minimum de
consommation responsable mettons aux
sécuritaire d'alcool et on est passé
justement ces autres qui avaient c'était
les architectes des derniers chiffres
donc le 2 3 par jour 10 15 par semaine
on dit si on reste là dedans on est
correct c'est pas super les risques sont
là mais les risques sont minimum pour la
santé puis là on regarde des nouvelles
recherches sur le cancer sur toute la
santé mentale ça avait été 100% sculpté
de 2011 il y avait même pas envie il y
avait aucune littérature assez avancer
là-dessus pour tenir compte de ça alors
que maintenant tu sais que
c'est la dépression n'est même pas
compte de ça
en disant mais aujourd'hui avec toutes
les études sont capables de dire voici
ce qui se passe maintenant quand tu
reçois ça Santé Canada ben c'est à eux
de prendre des décisions de mettre des
mises en garde ces bouteilles tout ça le
ccdus est organismes
qui prennent les qui les autres qui font
ils font leur job de scientifiques à
Sarah il envoie ça puis éducal qui va
recevoir le même rapport mais eux qui
est présentement l'organisme de
prévention mais c'était un peu décider
comme il faisait avant les autres qui
ont tout a reçu les trucs aussi des
dernières fois les mêmes les mêmes
repères en 2011 puis on choisit
là-dedans de prendre de faire ses
campagnes là puis aux autres leur
stratégie c'était de pas démoniser
l'alcool pour pas faire peur au monde
pour commencer à marteler l'alcool c'est
Satan tout ça c'est le mal enfin que d'y
aller un peu plus de chelac des annonces
et bonhomme allumettes là c'est tout un
peu funky les annoncent facteur une
façon de s'adonner quasiment le goût de
bois tellement que ça va être c'est
comme festif les autres dans leur
logique sont on s'adresse à plein plein
comprendre que ça boire et quelques
coffres à problématique enfin qu'on va
comme pas être trop moralisateur pas
trop faire peur au monde c'est un peu ça
leur approche mais en même temps
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
avec ces recommandations aux autres le
groupe il va il leur donne ils reçoivent
ça puis là il y a déjà commencé à faire
une nouvelle campagne on le laisse
tomber les chiffres là la dernière
c'était c'est toi le boss je peux te
l'avait vu la dernière campagne du
calcule non non
c'était quand même plus euh c'est un dos
de qui qui revient travailler que le
goût de boucher une bière ou son frère
il veut de l'alcool puis comme hop
finalement pourquoi que ça va m'apporter
de boire une bière c'est toi le boss
t'es responsabilise toi je pense que
c'est plus les gens c'est pas obligé de
boire vraiment besoin de boire
maintenant déjà sans sortir des des
chiffres c'est que c'était intéressant
c'est intéressant mais encore une fois
je veux dire il y a pas le mot santé
dans il y a pas le mot santé il y a pas
les les
politiques les risques on peut exposés
de manière claire c'est juste comme tu
es pas obligé de boire mettez c'est
comme si c'est pas c'est possible que
moi à mon avis parce convaincant que ça
bois pas beaucoup toi mais mettons
quelqu'un qui fait le parter pas mal il
va peut-être te dire ah il commence pas
à commencer pas à mettre des des des
fois nécrosées ces bouteilles puis tu
reçois super ta bouteille avec un bon
froid
même pas ça moi je veux ça en fait je
peux pas me dire waouh victoire grâce à
notre documentaire on a contribué à ça
je peux moto pitcher des tomates je
pense que une mise en garde ça serait
déjà minimum il y a zéro de ça c'est la
seule la seule substance
dans le guide des boissons puis des des
de l'aliment l'alimentation l'alcool qui
a pas de valeur nutritive de de la seule
petite substance pour active que pas de
mise en garde non plus qui dit que c'est
nocif ça serait un début ça ça va se
faire le j'ai eu une tu sais parce que
quand même eu
certaines communautés scientifique
notamment en cardiologie qui ont
post-bac un petit peu sur une
recommandation de ccdec
j'ai vu une enfilade de tweet que je
trouvais quand même intéressant
puisqu'on en discute c'était par rapport
au type de cancer qui était choisi puis
à la différence entre une donnée qui est
statistiquement intéressant versus
comment ça se transmet dans Vie type de
cancers mettons je sais pas exactement
c'était quel type de cancer mais c'est
quelque chose de
0,002% de chance de développer ce cancer
là puis que avec une consommation
mettons de 7 à 14
consommation par semaine tu doublais ta
chance mesdames messieurs 0,002 à 0,004
puis ce que le monde disait c'est que
les
rapports joue un peu sur cette espèce de
de peur là au niveau des données qui
sont statistiquement efficaces versus
qu'est-ce que c'est vraiment puis à quel
point est-ce que ça la nuance a pas été
faite pour monsieur madame tout le monde
qui reçoit ses informations là tu sais
je sais pas que si tu as réfléchir à ça
si tu penses à ça j'avais pas vu c'est
mais j'aimerais savoir ça moi j'aimerais
être au courant de ce qui sont en train
de faire une tempête dans un verre d'eau
je pense pas moi j'ai sûrement pas je
sais que les les cancers en plus c'est
plutôt logique là tu sais qu'ils ont
expliqué c'est toutes les organes que ça
touche quand tu bois de l'alcool tant
que ça tombe dans le sens maintenant tu
es l'argument boire un vent par jour
c'est bon pour la santé on s'entend qui
est en train de de violer
moi je m'appuie surtout c'est moi j'ai
pas la manque depuis qu'on se parle au
début j'ai dit quelques fausseté parce
que je suis pas dans toutes qu'est-ce
qui est un peu médical je suis vraiment
en dehors de de on va mettre des
compétences
un médecin qui écoute ça il va sûrement
dire que que
je m'av sais pas mais c'est sûr que une
animal les gens à qui on a parlé tu sais
il y avait des médecins dans notre
documentaires c'est 100% du monde qui
sont comme
c'est pas bon pour la santé l'alcool
c'est ça exactement
même si ça double ça dope toujours bien
peu importe c'est quoi le risque qu'il
soit faible ou pas c'est pas bon ta
santé ça c'est clair mais le pré l'idée
était plus de dire par ces ces médecins
là de l'Institut cardio ici à Montréal
qui disait
qui suppose qui qui
réfléchissait au fait que est-ce qu'il y
a un agenda
ultra
contre l'alcool par cette ce rapport-là
c'est un peu la question qui est
soulevait mettons on s'entend pour dire
que c'est pas bon ça augmente des
risques de toutes ces affaires pour de
vrai ça les augmente pour vrai ça c'est
hors de tout doux mais ce qui est un
agenda voulant
surexposer certaines données qui au
final dans le quotidien vont pas rien
changer
ne pas parler focale de ça il y a
longtemps
l'industrie de l'alcool ou le lobby de
l'alcool a eu un papier chèque en blanc
pendant quand même tout le temps
quand même depuis toujours Jésus-Christ
depuis la prohibition parce que ça a
commencé la Sok ça c'était aujourd'hui
c'était très très soulement tôt dans un
sacs en papier
aujourd'hui rentrée c'est le partage si
on s'entend que
depuis longtemps le bidon aussi
maintenant moi je voudrais je trouve que
c'est un peu du niaisage de rester d'un
chiffre 5 2 combien la longue deux par
semaine faites juste dire que l'alcool
c'est pas bon pour la santé point c'est
obligé de date c'est ça l'alcool arrête
parce que avant ça donne une fausse
perception ça que ça se met peut-être
une petite confusion moi quand j'ai
commencé documentaire puis comme disait
moi j'écoutais ça en diagonale les cinq
disques tout ça je me rappelais du
slogan à la modération bien meilleur
goût mais quand j'ai commencé j'ai vu 15
par semaine pour un gars honnêtement ma
première réaction c'était si moi ça va
bien 15 par jour buvait à peu près
environ tabarnak
par jour
à tous les matins pour avoir de 20 mois
ça me fait faire rapidement on va
devoirs suffit
c'est déjà un grand pas dans notre
société qu'on est on sort des chiffres
c'est pas bon comme la cigarette c'est
pas bon comme le pote c'est pas bon
comme le McDo c'est pas bon c'est ça
c'est pas des bonnes substances bonnes
pour ta santé à partir de là si tu veux
consommer tout ça vas-y mais c'est c'est
un peu ça les médecins à m'ont donné ils
peuvent pas ou les gens qui vont trouver
que c'est un peu castrant puis bon ok
c'est un c'est un un Stone du lobby
anti-alcool tu sais non c'est juste le
gros bon sang qui qui revient cogner
chez vous pour te dire que c'est pas bon
boire de l'alcool mais à ce stade bois
mais vas-y parle tu as le droit de la
vie est courte puis Yolo
classique
qui avait plein de monde qui prenaient
leur verre de vin rouge en pensant que
c'était à chaque souper en pensant que
c'était bon
il devait pas peut-être une grand-mère
qui reparle qui disait que c'est ça son
petit c'est quoi un genre de Jean ou je
sais pas quoi
mais le verre de vin déjà qui boit leur
tirage aux gens en disant que c'est bon
pour la santé et je pense que soyons pas
dupe là c'est tout des alcooliques qui
font semblant que c'est pas envoyé qui
mettent ça c'est le dos de la santé mais
peut-être que c'est bon Martin Junot le
cardiologue c'est sa ligne là le verre
de vin par jour c'est pas mauvais pour
le cœur il y a sûrement raison le gars
j'ai juste un vrai médecin j'ai le
challengerai pas là-dessus mais bon
c'est sûr que si tu mets la loupe sur
une affaire puis tu dis ok
il peut avoir des bénéfices sur tel truc
mais tu tiens pas en compte l'entièreté
du portrait exactement de rouge par
semaine minimum sur ton cerveau mais ça
va donner ça ça sort tellement face tu
mets tout ça ensemble
c'est c'est un peu responsable que des
médecins disent te prescrit de la c'est
comme ça un médecin dans le temps il y
avait des médecins qui qui vendaient qui
qui parlaient des sortes de clopes qui
faisait
tu verrais pas ça aujourd'hui là une
clope par jour c'est pas pire c'est bon
que ça sert pas de marche pendant ce
temps-là tu sais je pense pas que je
suis une prescription non plus le devoir
de 20 par jour là non tout ça je pense
pas qu'ils disent faites-le mais de le
fait de juste le banaliser c'est c'est
un drôle de message en 2000 aujourd'hui
il devrait dire c'est pas bon point
c'est pas bon l'alcool mais rendu là
virez pas fou non plus parce que ça
serait intéressant justement ton
enfilade de chiffres dans tes tweets de
de de c'est pas bon pour la santé mais
là il y a pas été pas là il y a ça comme
rien ça double j'aimerais ça aller voir
ce chef-là ça m'aiderait aussi
par rapport aussi je me suis un peu si
c'était Olivier Bernard qui parlait
dessus au système dans le livre de
d'aller voir ton cœur mais c'est des
fois des données qui sont présentées
d'une manière que ça a l'air vraiment
plus gros que c'est justement si tu dis
quelque chose qui te dis ça ça augmente
de 100% tes risques de ta cancer là puis
il est tabarnak 100% très 100% c'est ça
sonne énorme évidemment c'est pas des
trucs
au final ça double comme tu dis tu
passes de 0,002 à 0,004 c'est quand même
vraiment beaucoup l'argument des antivax
pendant
doubler tes risques de faire telle
affaire pour ton cœur si tu fais
vacciner tu sais c'est quand même que tu
vas doubler un risque
comme ça qui est pratiquement inexistant
peut-être que sur un million de
personnes là il va avoir deux personnes
qui vont développer je sais pas quoi
c'est comme ça vaut pas rien versus les
gains
parce que là c'est ça dans ce cas là il
y a des gains clairs alors que que la
consommation
à part le plaisir évidemment mais bon
concrètement il y a des vrais chiffres
sur les coûts de la santé associés à
laser
si ça c'était des notes c'était une
coupe de 100000 tu dis bon ben peut-être
on est en train de virer Cracotte pour
pas grand chose parce que ça va mais là
ça va pas bien hein peut-être que oui si
je me fais l'avocat du diable tu peux
dire oui mais la population vieillit
c'est notre perte normale
de tout ça peut-être que notre arme des
autres ont c'est pas une autre qui
rentre à l'hôpital à cause d'un problème
de d'alcool mais tu sais on est
peut-être en train de fabriquer notre
problème de santé de demain si on
continue à boire trop toutes les
semaines
je me rappelle d'autres là les gens
les premières broches qu'on brossait le
T je me suis repassé le commentaire
l'autre fois parce que genre j'ai vu une
caisse à 24
au dépanneur je me suis des fois on
achetait ça
tu revenais avec 6 chez vous gens pour
un samedi soir on avait 16 17 ans puis
cette information là c'était genre je me
rappelle même pas
jamais m'a être posé la question est-ce
que ça va me nuire sur le long terme
c'est juste comme on va en virer une
tabarnaka et on buvait là je vois
mettons trois bières puis comme tu
disais tantôt je suis quand même j'ai
envie d'aller me coucher mais on
défonçait on était jeune qui ont défoncé
des 12 packs des 24 packs c'est fou moi
aussi justement commencé après en
écoutant le documentaire puis en
m'informance le sujet si je repensais
cette année-là c'était de loin la
période de la vie dans le fond à 15-16
17 ans 18 que je buvais le plus toutes
les fin de semaine je vais bien plus
qu'aujourd'hui petit le pire c'est que
nous autres probablement qu'on était
quand même dans les modérée parce qu'on
faisait du sport puis tu on avait
peut-être un soir semaine qu'on
s'entraînait pas le lendemain matin
mettons que c'est qu'on l'échappait un
peu plus mais
mais en buvait c'était terrible
quand on sortait avant c'était tu
pouvais calme
fort c'est ça on devait beaucoup
si justement des blackouts des soirées
de
faire de fou et puis non seulement tu
sais justement admettons en écoutant le
podcast de youberman
non c'est pas la raison pourquoi que
c'est interdit pour les en mode 18 ans
c'est pas parce qu'on se dit bah ils
sont jeunes puis ils sont pas prêts à
prendre cette décision là c'est aussi
que quand on ton cerveau puis ton corps
ton corps en croissance ça bien plus un
effet beaucoup plus dommageable que
qu'un adulte qui boit affecter c'est
c'est c'est sérieux puis on dirait que
le moi mettons plus vieux aujourd'hui si
j'ai des enfants on dirait que je vais
être
André le cirque recommence
pas trop ouais c'est ça
c'est les autres vont sortir l'entonnoir
à leur tour on dirait que c'est comme un
CC qui perpétuel plutôt réalise aussi
c'était cave ça recommence à recommence
quand même tes enfants ils vont le faire
quand même mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les gens aujourd'hui il boit plus
parce qu'ils font de la mdr ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle
ça ça va être aussi des études qui vont
sortir dans dans plusieurs années où
est-ce qu'on va faire une génération
complète c'est rendu Alzheimer à cause
de ça en même temps les plus vieux vont
dire qu'en fait
mais j'avoue que là il y a de la là-bas
c'est sûr que ça doit tu peux pas
contrôler il y a pas le ministre
contrôle non non c'est ça c'est ça moi
je fais une petite
soirée que je bois pas mettons de moche
de moche et puis là je veux dire ça
jusqu'à date les effets négatifs
sont pas clair encore
oui je sais que c'est tout le monde fait
ça c'est populaire mais c'est le seul tu
prends plus un guest que la sqdc où tu
dis que c'est un truc il y a ça qui est
tout à fatiguant mais j'avoue qu'il y a
le paquet qui font ça ça donne le petit
le petit boss de forex
justement ça remplace comme
tranquillement un peu l'alcool dans les
soirées des fois c'est juste une petite
dose puis toute votre génération
d'anxieux ça les aide calmer la société
une fois que il y a le mec qui font ça
pour aller travailler juste pour rentrer
agoraphobie transport en commun sortir
de chez moi après la Pan très populaire
ça c'est un aspect de l'alcool aussi
que ça ça augmente ton base line
d'anxiété on fait que c'était en train à
une fréquence constante ça t'en prend
moins pour être anxieux fait que là tu
penses que tu tues ton anxiété en
arrivant chez vous puis en ouvrant une
bière mettons on peut en prenant ton
verre le soir mais ça fait juste
augmenter ton base line fait que là tu
es comme juste anxieux à plus d'efforts
puis de la roue tourne la roue tourne la
roue tourne c'est un depresseur
[Rires]
mon ami David qui m'a dit l'autre fois
genre que son père lui parce que il y
avait pas eu l'approche que tu dis que
tu aurais avec tes enfants c'est-à-dire
de là pas trop pas trop tôt pas trop
vite tu sais les mettre en garde parce
que c'est pas bon son père avait dit
la drogue de l'alcool c'est pas illégal
parce que c'est pas bon c'est illégal
par c'est trop bon genre c'est trop le
fun c'est fait que là tu le sais
c'est ça le problème
de nos parents c'est plus vieux que dans
leur temps c'était bien plus clean oui
mais ça chauffait avec une bière les
jambes
qui était quand même au noir ce qui
achetait mieux c'est à quel point que ce
soit j'en prends j'en laisse le sur
toute mort de bonheur de toute façon
génération
[Rires]
avant d'enregistrer tu disais que là sur
recevais c'est suite à au documentaire
et au dernier mois que là tu recevais
comme des demandes d'entre vous qui
était comme rendu un peu la
porte
mais mes bras sur la fin de semaine
j'ai une vraie réflexion je suis
conséquent avec ça j'essaie juste d'être
bien transparent enfin je veux pas non
plus booster que moi je trouve ça quand
même
gros de me retrouver comme ça j'étais
invité et puis je parle de sobriété mais
tu sais j'essaye tout le temps dès que
je peux de dire calmez-vous là j'ai un
cheminement à faire je le fais je n'ai
prospection réelle je m'en vais en
voyage avec ma famille d'ici un mois six
mois en Amérique du Sud je boirai pas je
m'en bats pas sur une vachement avoir en
famille FACTIVE je vois certainement
faire une genre de cure de 6 mois de
temps en temps mais ça a été j'ai hâte
de faire ça aussi puis j'y crois enfin
que je fais des efforts mais maintenant
si je peux pas je serai très très mal à
l'aide de dire que je suis rendu le
porter tendance je me trouve fake si je
fais ça parce que c'est pas réel puis tu
es en fait semaine où là je vais voir
une coupe de parquet avant de partir je
serai pas à l'eau là c'est juste que
c'est l'information qu'on voulait vendre
là-dedans que je suis content de tuer
dans ma job c'est rare que tu as
l'impression de faire quelque chose de
vraiment d'intérêt public puis ça fait
20 ans que je suis journaliste puis j'ai
fait des affaires des fois où tu te
couches le soir disant que tu as pas
fait une différence dans la société là
des articles bien sûr tout ça puis là
j'ai l'impression d'avoir fait quelque
chose qui qui fait un bruit utile même
si l'expression égale vaudrait mais que
ça j'ai l'impression que ça ça a été
utile les gens parce que je reçois
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de messages
qui sont contents c'est les autres
consentisés ça leur il savait pas ça il
y a un prix sur ce qui est du quel
surpris ça va pas que c'était le
monopole raconte leur histoire d'horreur
de de leur chambre
d'un problème de cancer de si enfin que
j'ai tout ça enfin je me sens un petit
responsabilité de savoir ça enfin que
c'est pour ça que je veux en parler plus
possible mais par transparence et
honnêteté je peux pas booster que j'ai
arrêté de boire complètement ça me fait
le documentaire me fait peur les
conclusions du documentaire aussi j'ai
pas beaucoup de mourir dans 5 ans à
cause que je suis chez le roi du
parterre tout ça je suis au courant mais
tu sais moi j'ai une vision de la vie
quand même que on s'en va pas au ciel
après
c'est là que ça se passe le fait que
j'essaie de c'est comme deux deux façons
deux idées qui s'entraîchers
est-ce que tu penses que que
te déranger ouais pour vrai je pense que
ça se traduit comment
ce matin sur un courriel de de la
nouvelle patronne d'éducale qui veut me
rencontrer factice
j'ai eu assez d'impact pour pas que ça
passe d'un créative et puis moi je
trouve je trouve ça intéressant d'y
aller journalistiquement surtout puis
maintenant je le vois aussi là que je
pense pas vous marier invité sinon je
jouais j'ai beaucoup d'invitations dans
les médias à cause de ça donc je le vois
que ça allait un impact certainement que
je reçois comme je vous ai plein plein
de messages
je vois que ça fait très âgé je suis
content parce que on était du peut-être
d'avoir collectivement d'avoir une
petite conversation sur l'alcool puis à
partir de là ben tu sais la vie continue
là
on va peut-être passer un autre dossier
prochainement encore une fois on les
adultes chacun prendra ses propres
décisions ouais avec les informations
qu'on a là mais moi tu sais tu dis je
trouve ça drôle d'être dans d'être
position là de porte-parole étant un
fêtard notoire je trouve que c'est que
c'est du génie en fait que ça soit toi
qui soit toi qui soit
la figure de ce documentaire là parce
que justement
va-t-il documentaire s'adresse
principalement aux gens qui consomment
qui boivent ça marche pas plus
en clair à recevoir ce message-là par
quelqu'un qui dit écoute moi je bois je
veux continuer de boire mais quand même
c'est important de savoir ça sur
connaître en toi versus quelqu'un qui
serait déjà arrivé avec la position de
dire
contre l'alcool Puiseux je veux juste
pousser son message contre alcool versus
c'est ça quelqu'un qui boit et qui qui
découvre des affaires
est-ce que est-ce que la mission où
est-ce que l'angle du documentaire a
évolué au fil de fil en aiguille en le
faisant j'imagine que oui
si j'étais le premier surpris là que ça
soit l'enquête choc et crédible tu sais
je pense pas qu'il m'avait casté pour ça
non plus je travaille sur bagnat depuis
un bout et puis je dis pas que je fais
de la merde mais je suis pas un
journaliste d'enquête là
et merci
c'est un peu pour ça qu'il me voulait je
pense qu'il voulait quelque chose de
plus de
de suivre mon parcours de santé de
consommateur plutôt au début le
documentaire a commencé pré pandémique
aussi
puis il y a eu un long moment on se
demandait où on s'en allait avec au
début et je notais toutes mes comptes
consommations sur un calendrier
plusieurs phases plus
interactif là au début genre de Super
Size 1000 genre que j'ai déjà fait avec
les boissons neiges
[Rires]
non mais le médecin qui me suivait qui
est Martin Gino le cardiologue qui
justement pas content après moi tout est
dans toutes mais là lui justement en
chemin il disait ça arrête ça le temps
super temps
mais bon je pensais que c'était au début
c'était ça qui j'avais aussi un
alcootest que je faisais avec les faut
que je je ne faisais pas ça du monde
qu'on avait commandé c'était plus une
note consommation ordinaire
on est entouré d'alcoolique fonctionnel
c'était vraiment ça au début l'angle une
réflexion sur notre consommation du
ordinaire parce que les fois qu'on
entend parler de l'alcool au Québec
c'est les extrêmes ceux qui ont tout
perdu à cause de l'alcool puis ceux qui
se trouvent bon parce qu'ils font le 28
juin entre les deux on est un paquet qui
boit personne pense qu'un problème mais
que tu reviens tu parles avec tes
collègues mais tout le monde est un pays
over tous les jours il y a du monde 400
bières deux Témo je trahi du monde
c'était comme question est bien par jour
puis était tout le temps alors le
lendemain fonctionnel c'était des pros
dans leur job mais c'est beaucoup
faculté c'était ça puis en chemin mais
c'est devenu une enquête en trouvant un
peu on a découvert en même temps que
quelques qu'on a fait le documentaire
sur le la bon il y a eu ça a commencé la
17 le l'analyse de du magazine de
landset qui qui était un peu un des deux
des dénominateur
qui disait que justement l'alcool c'est
pas bon c'est un peu les conclusions
qu'on voit là dans le landset une revue
scientifique les avait et après ça ben
le rôle d'éducalcool le rôle de la SAQ
puis là en comprenant tout ça mais on ne
fait que maintenant on était prévu dans
les grands reportages jusqu'à un repas
longtemps avant la diffusion puis un
moment donné je pense que des gens en
plus importants qui ont écouté ça qui en
fait
dès qu'on a été mis dans la case de
darkite c'est sûr que là ça on a on a
commencé à savoir plus des de l'intérêt
des gens vu le documentaire puis lancer
comment ça se faire inviter puis je
pense que ce qui nous aide aussi c'est
qu'on a pas que tu disais tantôt si
j'avais été abstiné depuis toujours
anti-alcool ben tu sais les gens ce
serait pas reconnu là-dedans il y avait
goûté ça pierre
il est parfait
[Musique]
ça je pense le côté non moralisateur ben
il y ait parce que tu sais ça se joue
quand même un documentaire un peu drôle
qu'on se prend pas au sérieux
ça je pense que ça nous a aidé les gens
se sont sentis qu'on se plus concernés
[Rires]
qui dit que l'homme est comme à son pays
quand il est à point zéro
trois mettons
plus drôle plus de ce que la performance
ultime de l'homme si on fait tout le
temps vous faites le temps être à ce
niveau là c'est comme tout va bien
évidemment
au début c'est comme
mais reste que
ça ça faisait partie tu vois de
l'inspiration aussi le fait que j'aurais
abandonné il a été envisagé que
peut-être que je le fasse là
une semaine mettons juste pour voir si
c'est vrai que je trouve parce que.08
pour les gens tu sais parce que
évidemment point zéroïde c'est le
fatidique
mais point 08 moi j'ai fait nez rouge
pendant plusieurs années quand j'étais
au rougeur universel puis on avait fait
le test en nez de se tester à point 08
point 0 8
je me suis dit en ce moment je prendrai
pas mon chat c'est la limite où est-ce
que tu es assez conscient pour pas
prendre ton short puis tu es pas rendu à
dire que de conduire encore
je serai pas capable comme effectivement
conduire c'est beaucoup plus qu'on est à
côté pendant une semaine
dans le film c'est un peu moins que ton
Mojo te confiant tu es un peu coquille
mais point 08 j'avoue que j'étais
surpris parce que quelqu'un qui nous a
donné le côté si on te fait des faits
des exercices là ça y est là enfin je
suis allé voir un show à Laval puis j'ai
bu deux peines un shot puis j'étais à
point 0,5 moi je me considérais je me
trouvais chaud dingue deux peines
shooter moi je
prendrai pas le voir le volant jamais
jamais là
j'avais le droit j'avais même encore un
peu de l'eau je pense que ça aussi là
c'est un problème là ben c'est beaucoup
point 0,8 pour vrai si tu bois toute la
soirée mais que se passe là une
consommation à l'heure tu seras pas ton
soirée tata soirée tu peux allumer ton
chambre puis tu es pas mal correct mais
toutes les provinces également
légalement
mais c'est sûr qu'il y a beaucoup
d'accidents qui doivent être faites avec
du monde sont du point 08 à cause de
faculté affaibli bah il y a beaucoup
d'accidents à cause de l'alcool point au
Québec c'est comme bizarre que on
pourquoi nous autres on est comme les
moutons noirs aussi de point 08 toutes
les provinces 1.05.05 toute la Canada
sauf le Québec
c'est une bonne question
intéressant
à tuer va aller écouter le documentaire
à faire sur mon uniforme
c'est des photos
[Rires]
Urbania puis là je m'en vais
de photos de voyage sur ton Instagram
ouais ouais sur mon Instagram très très
moi il est monté mon
sur les beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
sinon elle est vraiment c'est pas des
documentaire sur tout tv gratuitement
et mon album est en préparation avec un
album
très bon je travaille dessus sur
d'autres dossiers avant de partir ou
discuter les autres choses qui a
surveiller de ce que tu travailles en ce
moment
on va aller faire un reportage sur la
pêche sur la glace demain parce que la
saison était le prix du retard
Sainte-Geneviève de Batista je m'en vais
rencontrer Monsieur qui s'appelle
pistache ça promet d'être une bonne
rencontre je connais la mairesse de
s'étendre la Peyrade
[Rires]
sur l'eau dans le fond mais
blanc c'est laquelle que c'est des
brimbales puis tu cours dehors parce que
là
c'est pas la bonne personne
mais ça c'est un peu une raison pour
boire de la bière
surtout avec les hameçons il y a moyen
de 5 ans de l'Opéra de faire une belle
saison de pêche avec du bon chocolat
chaud oui oui tout ça
merci beaucoup